we're now moving into the phase of the
Trump presidency where he's not doing
short-term damage and he's not doing
medium-term damage but he is starting to
do multi-generational damage and that's
where I would rank the selection of
judge Brett Kavanaugh to replace Anthony
Kennedy on the Supreme Court so we've
already talked about the executive
orders which have sort of been some have
been meaningless which could be very
quickly undone we've talked about some
of the other short to medium term
impacts that Trump will have and sort of
the speed with which those could be
undone and Supreme Court selections are
the types of picks that because of their
very nature because of the lifetime
appointments that Supreme Court
positions represent this is how Trump
will influence and damage American
society and culture for a long time
particularly with the selection of a
relatively young person like Brett
Kavanaugh and completely unsurprisingly
abortion rights with the selection of
Brett Kavanaugh are at risk we will
likely see as Jeffrey Toobin stated
state level bans within 18 months of
this nomination
these are Roman Catholic quite religious
he worked for Independent Counsel Ken
Starr and argued for the impeachment of
Bill Clinton although now he says
conveniently for Donald Trump that he's
against probes of sitting presidents
particularly since they can't be
indicted anyway sounds like a bit of a
double standard but sounds perfect for
Donald Trump now you were going to hear
from the right that Brett Kavanaugh is
position on abortion is that he
considers roe v wade binding under the
principle of star a decisis star a
decisis the legal term the Latin term
for precedent basically it's been
decided and I am going to give you right
now insight into how the propaganda
machine works let's take it step by step
you are going to be hopefully disgusted
by what I'm about to tell you and show
you where did these people get the idea
that Brett Kavanaugh has been clear that
Rho V
is simply settled law because its
present precedent well if you looked
this morning at Brett Cavanaugh's
Wikipedia page you would see under the
subheading abortion a line that says
Cavanaugh has stated that he considers
roe v wade binding under the principle
of star a decisis and would seek to
uphold it but has also ruled in favor of
some restrictions on abortion that's
interesting that's what Brett
Cavanaugh's Wikipedia page says as of
this morning but the great thing about
Wikipedia is you can click a button at
the top of any page which is called
history and it shows you the revision
history and previous iterations of any
particular page and if you hit the
history button on Brett Cavanaugh's page
you'll notice that for a very long time
like before this guy was on the radar as
a possible Supreme Court nominee there
were very few edits made to his page and
recently the edits have been coming fast
and furious every few minutes so I went
back a few days not that long Pat just a
couple of days to see what did Brett
Cavanaugh's wikipedia page say on Sunday
for example before we knew that he was
going to be Trump's Supreme Court
nominee and if you look before he became
a SCOTUS contender
the only thing related to abortion on
his page was that it said in October of
2017 Cavanaugh joined an unsigned
divided panel opinion which found that
the office of refugee resettlement could
prevent an unaccompanied minor in its
custody from obtaining an abortion so
let me repeat that even though the right
is now saying this guy supports roe v
wade very clear he says it's just
precedent it's done 48 hours ago the
only abortion related information on his
wiki page was the fact that he agreed
with preventing people from getting
abortions in certain situations so then
I said well that's interesting it was
very different 48 hours ago what did the
abortion section look like 24 hours ago
when we knew he was a contender but not
yet the nominee and if you look 24 hours
ago you would have seen that under the
abortion section it said in May 2006
Cavanaugh stated
he would quote follow roe v-- wade
faithfully and fully and that the issue
of the legality of abortion has already
been decided by the Supreme Court that
is very different then it is settled law
based on star a decisis and I would seek
to uphold it and the footnote links to a
video and I clicked on the video because
I said hey something weird is going on
here a lot of change is being made which
is his position on abortion I looked at
the video that was quoted as the source
for Brett Kavanaugh supposed a desire to
uphold roe v wade and it's a video where
years ago when Cavanaugh was a nominee
to a federal judgeship Chuck Schumer
Democratic senator asked him what is
your personal position on roe v wade and
Kavanagh does not answer the claim made
in the wiki quotes this video and in the
video there is no evidence whatsoever
that that's actually Cavanaugh's
position take a look at this for since
my time is ending here the two other
questions do you consider roe v wade to
be an abomination i and do you consider
yourself to be a judicial nominee like
the president said he was going to
nominate people in the mold of scalia
and thomas senator on the question of
roe v wade if confirmed to the DC
Circuit I would follow roe v wade
faithfully and fully that would be
binding precedent in the court it's been
decided by the supreme court of your own
opinion you know and I'm saying if I
were confirmed to the DC Circuit senator
I would follow it's been reaffirmed many
times including in Planned Parenthood
very understand but what is your opinion
you're not on the bench yet you've
talked about these issues in the past to
other people I'm sure this the Supreme
Court has held repeatedly senator and I
don't think it would be appropriate for
me to give up nurse Angela the video
source for Brett Kavanaugh supposedly
supporting row v Wade is him merely
saying that if he were a federal judge
he would follow the law
that's not innovative that's not
remarkable that's not support for a
woman's right to choose
that is simply
not support for roe v wade it's his
realization that as a federal judge he
just has to follow the law and roe v
wade is the law that's like if I'm a
police officer and you ask me do you
support marijuana being criminal and I
say as a police officer I would enforce
marijuana laws well that's fine if
you're asking me to be a police officer
but if I'm going to be a Supreme Court
justice who maybe would decide whether
marijuana law would be criminal or or
civil or legal altogether it is a bogus
answer and this is the propaganda war
pad this is what it is and if you don't
go back and look at the citations and
look at the edits you might just say
look wiki says he's for it it's fine
yeah it looks like Cavanaugh tries to
have it both ways on all topics when he
was working for Ken Starr it was
perfectly acceptable to investigate the
sitting president now that Donald Trump
is president I guess it's not or when
Bush was president I guess it wasn't
same thing in abortion - he can take all
possible sides and maybe that will allow
him to skate through well you know how
it's gonna go when he gets asked about
this during the confirmation hearings he
will say some version of I would not be
able to comment as to how I would rule
on any issues that might come before the
court that would be inappropriate to
prejudge I will judge everything on its
merits he will get coy as they all do
and abortion rights are going to be
attacked and it's not even the actual
repeal of roe v wade that we should be
most concerned with I believe it's gonna
be a thousand small cuts
it'll be small restrictions pushing back
when one can get an abortion making it
okay to further restrict funds for
family planning services making it okay
to further closed down and just make the
practicalities of getting an abortion
more and more difficult it's gonna be a
thousand small cuts and before you know
it it won't even matter whether roe v
wade is actually repealed or not and
also extraordinarily concerning and
maybe the most stunning element of all
of this is that you remember how Trump
has said many times he could kill people
on Fifth Avenue and he wouldn't lose
support and you know how it's been
suggested now numerous times that a
sitting president cannot be indicted
Cavanaugh agrees to the extreme and in
2009 he actually wrote a law review
article
where he says the job of the president
is far more difficult than any other
civilian position in government and that
presidents should be exempt from civil
lawsuits and from criminal
investigations or prosecutions so if you
are already you know we had Andrew
Torres on and he said it's probably true
that you can't indict a sitting
president you'd have to impeach them and
then you would be able to indict them
potentially for things that they did as
president Cavanaugh is saying he doesn't
even believe in investigations of what a
sitting president is doing which is a
step further from saying you don't
believe that the president can be
indicted
not altogether shocking it's interesting
that Trump went with someone who has
actually written about this issue
specifically and and not altogether
surprising and I would guess that you
know ultimately this a nominee Brett
Kavanaugh he's not from the original
list that Trump said he would choose
from from like the Heritage Foundation
or whatever he was added to the list
more recently and I wouldn't be
surprised if Trump's personal lawyers
were actually involved in this election
on the basis of figuring out which
person might be best if the Trump Russia
stuff really blows up and it gets to the
Supreme Court and what's absolutely
stunning there are already people saying
should Cavanaugh if confirmed recuse
himself if anything related to Trump
Russia gets to the Supreme Court the
fact that that's even a conversation
means that this is an absolute
abomination yeah and of course if
Cavanaugh does recuse himself Trump
would say well then I never would have
picked you as my Supreme Court nominees
to begin with everybody jeff Sessions an
Attorney General everybody around Trump
is recusing themselves on this stuff so
if I had to bottom-line it for you or
kind of big picture for you in addition
to being hugely against abortion in
addition to being hugely favorable to
the current position of Trump's personal
lawyers with regard to the
investigations that are currently going
on about Trump the most relevant
judicial philosophy that we would look
at and identify with Brett Kavanaugh is
that he's big on executive power and he
doesn't seem so big on checks and
balances when it comes to the branches
of government and the executive office
and we I want to tell you what we can do
to prevent
sky from becoming the next Supreme Court
justice it's an uphill battle I oppose
this nomination but maybe if we can't
stop it we can still find ways to make
it as difficult as possible to get the
guy through so a few options are number
one on average it takes 11 weeks for a
Supreme Court nominee to be confirmed
that gets us to the very last few days
of September if we consider the process
to have started as of last night or as
of today that's very close to the
midterm election so we need to put
pressure on Democrats to say it's too
close to the midterms we need to let
people have their say and vote in
November on November 6th of 2018 before
we actually hold confirmation hearings
push for that will they actually get it
together and press for that I'm talking
about Democrats I don't know but we have
to push for that number one number two
once we know which Republicans might not
necessarily vote against this guy but
maybe just say let's give people an
opportunity to vote before we hold the
confirmation hearings target those
Republicans not for harassment but for
encouragement okay I don't know whether
it might be Susan Collins or Lisa
Murkowski I already got a voicemail from
a viewer saying David it's not gonna
happen forget about Murkowski and
Collins they're all totally gonna
support this guy try to get these
Republicans who necessarily aren't
necessarily opposed to Kavanagh per se
but might be willing to say let's let
people vote first because that might be
a way to block it I'm also pretty
worried about Democrats thing unified
against this pick I think there were
three Democrats Heitkamp Donnelly and
Manchin who voted for Neal Gorsuch
that's correct
coincidentally they're also up for
re-election in 2018 in the red states so
they may support Cavanaugh knowing that
their voters like him too and want to
get rid of abortion right it's possible
that just getting one or two Republicans
to say let's wait until after the
midterms it won't be enough if you get
those more right-wing Democrats to say I
support it and then the other
possibility is try to bust a quorum
right you need 51 senators in the
chamber physically to have a quorum and
debate and vote on a Supreme Court
nominee Republicans of 51 seats for
health reasons john mccain has been
missing
if 47 Democrats and two independents
don't attend and McCain isn't there
there's no quorum if McCain does attend
or a replacement is named and McCain
steps aside
you only need to convince one Republican
not to participate again if you've got
all the Democrats and as Pat is pointing
out when you've got people like Joe
Manchin in the Senate can't say for sure
that you're actually going to have all
of the Democrats but the best strategies
if you're hearing me lay out all the
possibilities the best strategies are
all connected to Democrats taking over
the House and Senate in November if not
even a successful delay through the
midterms is only delaying the inevitable
and that's it well hey I mean Mitch
McConnell said it himself you can't have
a Supreme Court justice confirmed during
an election year and this is a midterm
election year we can't do it will
Democrats have the testicular fortitude
to hold them to it though I am I want to
say the answer is yes
I just am skeptical I got just about
testicular fortitude itself about having
the votes - yes the ladders more
important yes well I think proverbially
both are basically the exact same thing
and that must be the top goal the
primary goal it's what we all need to be
working on which is taking control of
the House and Senate in November of 2018
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and boy do we have a good
show for you today I'm actually glad
about today's show oftentimes I'm like
it shows okay this is one of the good
ones